We talked
about the 60 Minutes interview
last night
that Lesley Stahl did with Congressman
Marjorie Taylor Greene.
I think we have a clip.
Let's play it for people
who didn't see the whole thing.
Are you saying
that you don't stand by
what's on your social media?
Well,
of course I stand for
what's on my social media,
but at times not
You're not always in control.
We have all kinds of people
that work on our social media.
Did you apologize for your position
on Parkland, Florida?
What was my position
That it was a false
I don't know
if you actually have my post.
No, I never said Parkland was a false.
Did you?
No, I've never said that.
We fact-checked before.
I got to this interview.
Have you fact
checked all my statements
from kindergarten through 12th grade
and in college?
The Democrats are a party of pedophiles.
I would definitely say so.
They support grooming children.
They are not pedophiles.
Why would you say that?
Democrats, Democrats support
even Joe Biden.
The president himself
supports children
being sexualized
and having transgender surgeries.
Sexualizing children is what
pedophiles do to children.
Wow.
Okay.
She is someone who, in just her second
term in Congress, has got a lot of power,
a lot more power than she had before,
thanks to Kevin McCarthy.
Fundraises a lot of money.
So, yes, there are critics who are saying
why did 60 minutes go for that platform?
I think Leslie Saul did a good job
in that interview.
And I just wonder what you took
away from it. Yes.
I mean, there's a fellow Leslie
Stahl family.
I can't fault them.
I mean, 60 minutes is interviewed,
you know, rapists and hitmen and all
sorts of people,
you know, who are who are in the news.
I mean, I think that
one of the most interesting things
happening here
is that Marjorie
Taylor Greene, who obviously, as you say,
is a significant figure.
Whatever you think of her has
a lot of power in Washington, is
it was made a decision
to attempt to kind of
get to a more mainstream place
by doing things like 60 minutes.
We have a big story like Diego Baez
coming out this morning
and said before about really about how
this is part of her media strategy
to embrace the media
she criticizes around the Sanders
for not talking to the media enough
and yet at the same time
she's trying to become more mainstream
she she's still
calling Democrats pedophiles and she and
I don't know
if you can do both of those things
at the same time
she is trying to sort of say look
this is the Republican Party now
sort of take us or leave us
and you have to deal with
us on our terms.
But she
but she is also walking away
from some of the crazier substance,
some of it
and saying she was misled,
saying she was like a normal
American is basically true.
A normal American
who was reading all sorts
of nonsense on Facebook and believing
a lot of it.
I also found it really interesting
that she told
Leslie Stahl
that the reason she got in
and ran and left
the construction business, etc.,
is because of her
fellow Republicans,
not because of Democrats.
Yeah.
I mean, you know,
I think she really does embody
this kind of new Trump
movement in the party.
Whether it totally takes over the party
or not is an open question.
But I think the idea,
which was a bit of always
a bit of a fantasy
that journalists, that Democrats
just sort of
can ignore,
that wing of the Republican Party
is totally over.
And the 60 Minutes interview
sort of codifies that in a certain way.
It just
you're not putting her in that group
when you're
when you're talking about
who else 60 minutes is interview.
I just know how people
say thanks
for letting me clean that up, Caitlin.
No, I'm just saying
they've interviewed people
far more controversial
than Marjorie Taylor
against her prominence in the Republic.
But that is a constant struggle
that we have been dealing
with since Trump
or Trumpism is
who do you give a platform to?
Who is legitimate and who's not in this
especially when you have election deniers
and people who are just,
you know,
making things up as they go along with.
No, not based.
In fact,
do you actually put them
on traditional media to elevate them?
That is a struggle that,
you know, that we all face.
So I can understand why. Yeah.
And you have to be fast on your feet
as a journalist
the way the way Lesley Stahl is.
Yeah.
Just as interesting why she did it
as why they did it.
To your point,
Ben Smith, thanks for bringing the table.
Thank you.